national parle même de la
"tempête d'une génération".
Sébastien Desrosiers.
(clics des clignotants)
- Dans des condionons pareilles,
difficile, voir impossible
de se déplacer. La neige
la vie dure aux Américains.
L'L'une des journées les plus
achalandées de l'année
dans les aérop
vire au cauchemar pour
bien des voyageurs.
auprès de ma famille", dit-il,
un cadeau pour sa fille en main.
les moeurs, c'est le temps
ou jamais.
"C'est un peu fou, déplore cet
quand je pourrai partir."
(en anglais)
Le secrétaire aux Transports
explique que des milliers
de vols sont annulés.
Des alerteururururururururururus
de millions d'Américains,
de la frontière canadienne
dans des États comme le Montana
et le Wyoming, jus l l l l l l .
"Certaines régions enregistrents
froides en une décennie
ou plus", jusqu'à -45 °C
Le service météorologique
américain parle d'mpmpmpmpête
comme on n'en voit qu'une fois
"Ce n'est pas une journée de
tempête comndndndnd vous étiez
enfant, insiste le président
Biden. La situation pourrait
par endroit, c'est à prendre
au s
Plusieurs États ont déclaré
l'étenenenenence, comme
Le front froid doit
s'intensifie, , , , , persister
encore quelques jours.
Ici Sébastien Desrosier